what's up guys and welcome to Harley's
hobbies did you know where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into the
newest tech products today we're taking
a look at why you shouldn't buy a GPU at
any cost but before we delve into that
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you guys would like to stay updated
with the latest tech news related to
gaming and pcs so what's the problem
why shouldn't you buy a new GP right now
well the main reason is because the next
series of GPUs from Nvidia is coming out
very soon and it is promising a really
good performance so it doesn't really
make sense to buy an almost updated GPU
especially overpriced the new series is
also expected to be really well priced
so that's a plus as well so what exactly
happened well recently it was actually a
leak about the GTX lemonade
specs now before we go any further just
keep in mind that these are just rumors
and leaks so they could very well be
false so just make sure to keep that in
mind so what do these rumors suggest
well I have a dedicated video in which I
cover the GTX eliminating thoroughly but
here's just a quick recap according to
these specs the GTX 1180 is going to be
really close in performance if not
exceed the type XP on top of this it has
G DDR six memory as opposed to the gddr5
X memory in the typing XP and it draws
less power as well and the most
intriguing part is that according to the
leak it's only going to cost $700 which
is the same MSRP as the GTX 1080 at
launch so as you guys can see it's
really offering a great value when you
look at how much performance that gives
you but when exactly is the gtx 1180 and
all the other variations coming out and
vidya unfortunately didn't give us any
hints at GTCC
however gamers Nexus was actually able
to get in contact with SK Hynix who is
actually the memory producer for Nvidia
and SK Hynix college gamers Nexus that
they're going to start mass production
of gddr3 in just three months so
according to them they're gonna be
starting their mass production of gddr3
at the end of June or around the
beginning of July as a result we can
probably expect it and see the GTX 1170
and 1180 at the end of July or the
beginning of August
so pretty much mid to late summer and
then we can probably see the 1160 and
1150 here the end of the year and then
other variants like the 1150 Ti and
lemon atti
to come out sometime next year this
actually coincides with what Tom's
hardware and this rumour says and so
that's probably the expected timeframe
for these new GPUs so as you guys can
see it's just around the corner and it's
definitely worth the wait really high
numbers are great and all but it really
doesn't matter if it doesn't deliver a
really great real-world performance and
so what real-world performance can we
expect out of these new cards well for
as for the GTX solemnity that
performance should be very similar to
what we were seeing with the Titan XP
right now so pretty much most if not all
current games should be able to run up
mac settings 4k at at least 60 frames
per second most should actually run at
70 or 80 frames or even higher but at
least 60 usually on top of this the GTX
1180 should excel in qHD ultra wide
gaming or triple monitor 1080p gaming so
if you guys are interested in that then
this may be worth waiting for as well so
by now you guys probably understand why
these new GPS are worth waiting for and
why they're offering so much great
performance but some of you guys may
still be like well GP prices have just
started to come down why do they go back
up well wouldn't I get screwed then well
that is true but the thing is GPU mining
while it is still profitable and you can
make money out of it there's the hype
that was around it at the beginning is
simply non-existent
there is simply just not a huge craze
around it and as a result there's not as
many people jumping in on to it and by
new mining setups with several graphics
cards at the same time also on top of
this the difficulty to mine
cryptocurrency is continuously
increasing so as a result that's also
deterring many people from starting
cryptocurrency mining right now
furthermore a company named bid made
actually revealed an ASIC miner for
aetherium if you guys didn't know it
theorem is one of the most popular
cryptocurrencies to be mined with GPUs
and as a result people who are
specifically just one of mine etherium
may jump on to these new Asics so what
are a six a six are an
application-specific integrated circuits
and they just do one task so in this
case it's simply just mine in theory 'm
so wouldn't that reduce the diversity
that miners have well that is true but
this ASIC is promising really great
performance for example a GTX 10 atti
that is fully overclocked and it is at
100% power limit will only do about 37
mega hashes second
yeah it'll consume 343 watts this new
ASIC is supposed to consume about 750
watts but it'll produce 650 mega notches
a second so as a result it's about 20
times more performance for just double
the power consumption so as you guys can
see it's much more effective on top of
that this is specifically built for
mining so the performance per dollar is
probably much better for miners so as a
result if your theory continues to be
the main cryptocurrency for miners with
GPUs then a lot of them may switch over
to the ASIC and that would lead to GPU
prices to continue to follow also Nvidia
and AMD have been taking action to try
to improve the GPU stock situation right
now and we are finally starting to see
the effects of their actions so as a
result in my opinion I think GP prices
are gonna continue to drop and hopefully
reach MSRP wants RAM prices stabilized
as well so it's probably quite obvious
why you guys should wait if you're
looking at getting an eleven seventy or
eleven eighty or
any a high-level card but is it worth
waiting it for thinking about admit to
your card like the eleven fifty or
eleven sixty which is coming at the end
of the year well in my opinion if you
really don't need an upgrade right now
and it would just be a nice thing to
have that you should definitely wait for
these we don't really know what
performers they're gonna offer but what
we do know is that in via has a lot of
performance to offer and it is very
likely that they match prevision
original gaps for example last
generation the gtx 1060 was about equal
to 980 and as a result this generation
we probably see that the eleven sixty is
equal to the ten eighty but it'll cost
us a lot less than what the ten eighty
came out for especially with the
overpriced situations right now so as
you guys can see the eleven sixty would
perform much better than the ten sixty
and be offered at a much better price so
i definitely recommend that you guys
wait now if you really don't care about
some extra performance or the little bit
of money that you may be able to save
and obviously might as well just go
ahead and buy a GPU right now but for
the vast majority of you guys i really
recommend that you guys consider waiting
for these new GPUs before you make any
rash decisions that you may regret so
what do you guys think about all of this
do you think these rumors are way over
exaggerated and that none of this is
actually going to happen or do you think
that it's about time that Nvidia brings
out something like this make sure to
post what you guys think down in
comments below because I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think also if you guys like this
video then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing if you guys would
like to see more videos just like this
one but until next time bye
[Music]